boom
[Music]
the first one is it's not that I go like
this and turn them that's not going to
cause the disorganization okay all of
all you did was take this same
relationship you see where you come pull
me that way and I've just moved it over
here and you can still pull me that way
see that so the rule of the inward
spiral is that your elbow comes to a
halfway between your midline and your
shoulder line you get that so when you
go like that that's in the same line
with the shoulder I have young and y'all
here it's not gonna work so when you go
here and that's what happen when you go
down goes down what that doesn't change
just because you turn so bring that
elbow finish your spiral second thing I
shoot how did you bring her that way
you're not shopping on that way you
still have the same ip you see because
what happens when you show the head is
they slip out so keep that keep the IP
adhesion
[Music]
in the movie
Oh
[Music]